Für seine Landsleute inszeniert er sich gern
als stark und männlich, und auch gegenüber
dem Ausland lässt er keine Zweifel daran,
dass er Russland zu alter Stärke zurückführen will.
Wladimir Putin bestimmt seit der Jahrtausendwende
die Geschicke Russlands - und seine Macht
will er in absehbarer Zeit auch nicht abgeben.
Konstantin Kalaschew, politischer Analyst:
"In Russland gibt es seit Jahrhunderten das
Konzept des Vaters der Nation.
Es gibt eine Sehnsucht nach einem Vater der
Nation, und Putin füllt diese Rolle aus.
In paternalistischen Gesellschaften scheuen
die Menschen eigene Entscheidungen, sie lassen
lieber andere die Entscheidungen fällen."
Und Putin handelt.
Russlands militärisches Eingreifen in der
Ukraine oder seine schützende Hand über
dem syrischen Machthaber Baschar al-Assad
haben tiefe Gräben zu westlichen Staaten aufgerissen.
Kritiker werfen ihm die Aushöhlung der Demokratie
in Russland vor.
Bei 80 Prozent der Russen ist der Kreml-Chef
dagegen so populär wie nie.
Wadim und Ljubow, Anhänger von Wladimir Putin:
"Die, die ihn nicht mögen, sind doch nur
neidisch auf ihn, ganz einfach.
Weil sie die Wirtschaft und ein so großes
Land nicht so gut führen können wie er es kann."
Bei der Präsidentschaftswahl am Sonntag strebt
Putin sein viertes Mandat an.
Wer ihm politisch gefährlich werden könnte,
wie sein wichtigster Kritiker Alexej Nawalny,
den lässt Putin durch die Justiz kaltstellen.
Seine sieben Herausforderer sind jedenfalls
nicht mehr als Zählkandidaten.